لطالما حظيت الانتخابات الرئاسيه
الامريكيه باهميه كبيره حتى قبل اشهر من
موعدها واستطلاعات الراي لا تتوقفوا عن
رصد حظوظ المرشحين وتارجحها لدى الناخبين
اخر هذه الاستطلاعات لا يبدو انها تصب
كثيرا في مصلحه الرئيس الحالي
فوفقا لاستطلاع عن اجرته ياه نيوز
بالتعاون مع شركه يوجا البريطانيه للابحاث
تبين ان 68% من المسجلين في الانتخابات
يعتقدون ان بايدن البلغ من العمر 80 عاما
كبير جدا بالنسبه لولايه اخرى ومن بين
الناخبين الديمقراطيين وافق ثمانيه على ان
تقدم بايدن في العمر يمثل مشكله حقيقيه
فيما قال 34% انهم لا يدعمون هذا الراي
كما قال اغلبيه
المستقلين وتبلغ نسبتهم 71% ان سن 82 كبير
جدا على ان يبدا به بايدن فتره ولايه
ثانيه كرئيس لامريكا